[Music]
[Music]
the next speaker is Hans bethe who's
known in the physics community as the
person who knows everything and has done
almost everything I remember the when I
first no no that's wrong I remember at
the early Rochester meetings on high
energy physics whenever there is a
question has this experiment been done
has this calculation had done what is
the result of this what is known about
this automatically every had turned to
Professor bethe and his answer was
awaited and furthermore believed and he
always answered to there probably is no
field of physics to which he has not
made a important contribution he
received a Nobel Prize in 1967 for the
discovery of the carbon cycle and he has
a source of energy generation in the Sun
professor Bader was born in Germany came
to the United States as a refugee from
the Nazis he arrived at Cornell in 1935
and more or less has been there ever
since with the exception of course of
the of the years of the Second World War
where he worked here for a while and
then in Los Alamos where he was where he
was central in the construction of the
first nuclear weapons he was the leader
of the theoretical group there ever
since
while conducted while engaging actively
in in physics research and teaching
he has worked rationally and effectively
to exploit and to understand and to
contain the nuclear fire which he helped
to invent he was my thesis advisor 38
years ago it was hard but I learned a
lot and survived so it's a real pleasure
to welcome him back to MIT professor
bethe his title today is solar neutrinos
[Applause]
that's okay I'm sorry how this works so
you can turn it on
stink I don't use that yes
or its back
Sciences thanks for the welcome I want
to collect your introduction by one
point I have never worked on general
relativity and I don't is don't intend
to do so
I'm happy to be here to join in
congratulations to Phil Morrison but it
is also a sad occasion for me I'm quite
used to getting old but it is very
depressing if young people get old also
well when I met Phil he was 28 and a
young man now they tell me he is 70
which is hard to believe but one thing
has remained unchanged he always gave us
terribly exciting ideas insights and he
still is Atlas today so I wish feel that
he will remain in this situation for
many years to come
now I have to warn you are that this
talk will be very different from dr.
Sagan's talk it is scientific and it
will contain a number even the number of
algebraic formulae that's terrible I'm
going to talk about the subject that
has been very active for the last year
namely the subject of neutrinos from the
Sun for many years this has been a great
puzzle and to talk about that let me
start by telling you the nuclear
reactions which are supposed to go on in
the Sun they are listed here
and many of them produce neutrinos the
fundamental reaction of course is the
the this doesn't seem to work
fundamentally actually is the top one
which is the encounter of two protons
giving a deuteron a positron and a
neutrino and then most of the deuterons
which are formed in this way finally go
through this the action making helium
four that gives the big energy but
occasionally they make velarium seven
which that happens maybe one time in a
thousand and the radium 7 then emits
another neutrino and then again in very
rare event velarium seven will capture
another potent and give a very odd
nucleus boron eight which produces
neutrinos of tremendous energy 14 MeV
here I have given the energies C means
continuous spectrum and
the this is the maximum energy of the
continuous spectrum in two reactions you
get a definite energy neutrino well the
question is can you observe the
neutrinos it is very difficult to
observe neutrinos of about 1 MeV that is
well known and it is also well known
that it gets a little easier if the
neutrinos have higher energy and then in
this connection then really Fowler and
John Bercow had a very good idea they
said well we might use flow and 37 there
is a state in argon 37 which is very
similar to the join 37 state it's a
so-called analogue state and therefore
they transition the capture of a
neutrino by chlorine-37 giving this
analog state in series 7 which is highly
excited by 6 million electron watch this
is a super allowed transition that isn't
the transition as easy as any neutrino
capture can ever be and so they decided
let's take chlorine-37
and observed the argon 37 which is
formed ray Davis of Bo came now if the
University of Pennsylvania has now tried
to observe the capture of solar
neutrinos for nearly 20 years
he uses a tanker of carbon tetrachloride
he flushes the argon out by helium and
argon puts the argon into a Geiger
counter and using uses the decay of our
137 which takes place by capture offer
an atomic electron in Lakeisha giving
chlorine 37 and a neutrino of course you
can't observe that neutrino either but
you can observe that the resulting atom
is missing a K electron thereupon it
emits x-rays of a few kilowatts and
those who can observe the well this is
the principle of the of the observation
but and in and indeed Davis didn't
observe a neutrinos but only about the
third of the predicted number
this is summarized in an article by
Davis and two collaborators going back
to 1981 well so what's wrong
the main person who investigated this
problem has been John back all of the
Institute of Advanced Studies he has
tried almost anything in the theory of I
renew clear reactions or the
constitution of the Sun to try and clear
up this puzzle to no avail
it just doesn't remove the discrepancy
the way they go about it is that maybe
the temperature in the center of the Sun
is lower then has been generally
supposed and for that purpose they need
information about the opacity of solar
material under different conditions
density and temperature there is a lot
of contributions by people at Los Alamos
and Livermore but the result remains the
same there is a discrepancy by a factor
of three or maybe four at the same time
Willy found int scope experimental group
at Caltech have we examined the nuclear
reactors and have found that the cost
section measurements for the reaction
leading to bavarian 7 october 1/8 that
these measurements were correct in spite
of some people from other laboratories
who had doubted that well the whole
problem was we examined very carefully
in 1982 by baikal and others in very
beautiful paper in reviews of modern
physics in which they discuss in
particular power hours of each step of
the argument of course one point in the
argument everybody believes namely that
the Porten Porten reaction
makes the energy in the Sun not only is
it the logical thing to assume but in
addition the general idea of
thermonuclear reactions in stars has led
to a very detailed understanding of the
further evolution of stars and in
particular all the details of the red
giant formation and evolution I
especially asked but called the other
day in a long telephone conversation how
here is he is of his results and he said
well we have gone through all the steps
we have given results with poverty were
three times the standard error I don't
believe there's any way to escape the
conclusion well one way was once
proposed by with a fella he called it
the desperate theory everybody knows
that the light comes out of the Sun only
after some 5 or 10 million years so what
we see today is energy which was
produced maybe 10 million years ago so
maybe the Sun was hotter in those days
more luminous than it is today which is
would be another sad conclusion because
it would predict that we would go into a
severe Ice Age in a few million years
that's less threatening than nuclear
winter but still
not very not very promising by calling
others made a modified theory whose
results are given here but in the
meantime they have gone back to the
theory of 1982 the theory after all
collections predicts that you should
observe on earth about six
snoo that's a funny unit it only ended I
won't explain it it tells you how many
counts mr. Davis Auto observe but this
experiment gives only to snow now it is
somewhat frustrating to rely on that
funny nucleus boronate would be much
nicer to observe directly the neutrinos
which come from the combination of two
Porter's because we know exactly how
often that must happen because that
gives us the energy which the Sun emits
every second the so called solar
constant well to avoid reliance under
their side chain it was proposed many
years ago to use a different detector
namely gallium 71 and the only thing
that's wrong with that proposal is that
gallium is a very very elements and
therefore terribly expensive but it
obviously was an important experiment to
do to find out the solution to
is puzzle well the National National
Science Foundation unfortunately
rejected the proposal several times to
carry out this experiment the Europeans
are somewhat more open to suggestion so
this experiment is going to be done by a
collaboration of Italian French and
German physicists in which will be
carried out in gan Sasso in Italy and is
being started
now this gallium experiment measures
directly the neutrinos which are made in
the proton-proton reaction and I have
written down here the capture rates in
these funny units new in four three
detectors don't pay any attention to
that this young the chlorine which has
been used observes practically nothing
on the portal portal reaction and the
observation comes mostly from Miriam
seven and four and eight by contrast
gallium would observe mostly Porten
Porten neutrinos some velarium seven and
very few born eight it also will give a
lot more snow in gallium the neutrino
capture yields to germanium and the main
IAM being an analog of carbon in the
periodic table lends itself to a very
ingenious detection scheme proposed by
davis is a good chemist you make
germanium so
the problem remains why are there only
1/3 as many neutrinos as they ought to
be it was suggested fairly early that
maybe neutrinos transform into each
other
namely we know there are different kinds
of neutrinos electron neutrinos and new
neutrinos antineutrinos and it was
suggested that maybe these neutrinos are
not the ones which propagates into a
space and that's a very standard
occurrence in particle physics you know
about it probably in the case of came as
an x' and there are many other examples
the particles which interact with other
particles are usually not the same as
the particles which propagate in free
space so then you assume that via
neutrinos are not equal to these and if
that is so then neutrinos which I shall
call u 1 and u 2 will propagate and and
that will have the consequence that in
free space neutrinos oscillate between
electron neutrinos am you neutrinos -
claimed at one time that he had observed
such oscillations using the neutrinos
from the Savannah River reactor but
later experiments did not confirm his
results in fact experiments recently
done at CERN find
a certain result which involves two
quantities namely the difference in mass
of these neutrinos and the anger of
coupling the I I go into that a little
more later namely the electron neutrino
is not quite a neutrino new one but they
are off by a certain angle theta and the
CERN experiments show that the square of
the mass difference times sine square of
twice that anger must be less than point
zero three electron white square this is
the dimension because of the mass the
direct experiments on the mass of the
electron neutrino show probably by now
that this mass is less than ten electron
was very far from this number
now if oscillations were to exist then
the electron neutrinos from the Sun
might be converted into item you are tau
neutrinos on the way to the earth for
this you need a mass difference greater
than 10 to minus 14 and but you need
desperately that the coupling angle be
very large namely that the three
neutrinos maximally different from the
neutrino is interacting with electrons
or muons that is very unlikely but it
and APRI it cannot be ruled out
completely
so this was the situation until recently
and recently two Russian scientist my
faith and Smirnoff proposed a theory
which I believe is the correct theory
and they use the mixing of neutrinos but
in a much more intelligent original way
then then I discussed in the last slide
I assume only two neutrino types
electron and you are neutrinos and in
vacuum they will they are covered in
terms of the three neutrinos nu 1 and u
2 and 1 commonly writes that the
electron neutrino is cause of a certain
coupling angle theta times the free
neutrino nu 1 plus sine theta thanks you
two and the muon neutrino of course is
orthogonal to that then the if the three
neutrinos have mass M 2 and M 1 you can
write the mass matrix in this form there
is a diagonal term which is of no
relevance plus another term which
contains the difference of the two
masses and times this very simple matrix
which is non diagonal in terms the first
of all refers to electron neutrinos the
second row to Munich Remus now so far it
is no different from from the last slide
but now they make use
of a theory which was developed by
Wolfenstein of the Carnegie Tech and
published in Physical Review in 1978 he
says as follows neutrinos when your
trainers are in matter then all
neutrinos interact with matter by means
of the neutral weak current but that's
of no interest because it's the same for
all nude neutrinos it doesn't help
convert one into the other
however the electrons also will interact
with the electron neutrinos n none other
by the charge we can't in which an
electron is absorbed by a proton it
becomes a neutrino plus a neutron and
this has the consequence that there is
effectively in matter a potential energy
for neutrinos which is the universal for
Fermi constant G multiplied by the
electron density number of electrons per
unit volume so far the voice instant
theory it says then that the relation
between momentum and energy of a
neutrino to always like this the
momentum square plus mass square is not
equal to e square the energy square but
energy minus the potential energy
squared
and this potential energy which only
exists for electron neutrinos I expand
this is equivalent to having an extra
mass for electron neutrinos which is
equal to 2e twice Lily the neutrino
energy times that potential energy and
so now my mass matrix gets added to it
and interaction term which is this - Evi
and that can be written in this way it's
proportional to the density of the
matter and to the energy of the neutrino
and I call that a now I add this to the
mass matrix and this will add to the
just to the electron part of the mass
matrix electron neutrino pop it will add
a term here and I ordered in such way
that I added 1/2 a here and minus 1/2 a
father mu and neutrino and Delta here
it's the difference in mass the mass of
the essentially Munich we know minus the
mass of the electron neutrino and
remember you always have to use the
square of the masses
now therefore obviously when you look at
this equation you will see that the
difference in masses becomes smallest
when the a which is proportional to the
density is equal to Delta R times cosine
2 theta
and then you have a minimum in the
difference of the two masses and I will
show you a curve of what that of the
consequence of that namely there are two
possible values for the mass square of a
neutrino if you have no density of
electrons then you have the electron
neutrino here at a low mass you and your
trainer at a high mass but when you get
to the point where they where this
condition is satisfied that a is equal
to the difference of mass quia that's
this point then at this point you can
probably not see that faint line at this
point the electron neutrino would get a
bigger mass than the muon your trainer
but there is the that the non diagonal
term in the matrix which means that
actually the curves do not cause but
this curve which starts as the electron
neutrino ends up at high electron
density as mu nu Traynor and vice versa
and so this means then a very
interesting thing and that's now the
theory of my fair and Smirnov if you
start
well let me first say the the forgiving
you three no energy there is a certain
density at which the two curves cost and
that density is determined by the
difference in mass of munich reno and
electron neutrino and by the university
family constant which we know very well
so at present the difference of the
masses of the two neutrinos is not known
but it surely is a constant of nature
and therefore this lambda is a certain
number which we don't know but it's it's
a number you know let's assume that
neutrinos are produced at a certain
density or one near the center of the
Sun then as they travel out through the
Sun they will go through this resonance
if the energy is greater than the energy
then exerting critical energy which is
equal to that lambda divided by the
density at the center of the Sun if
however the so if this is the case then
they will automatically change one down
the green curve starting out as elected
as electron neutrinos running down the
green curve they become mu neutrinos and
they change their by into mu neutrinos
and that means they become unobservable
because you neutrinos can only be
changed into in Matta they could only be
changed into MU mesons which have a mass
of a hundred million electron watts and
no neutrino which is produced in the Sun
has anything like that energy so the
those neutrinos therefore which are
created at a density above the crossing
point go down the green curve and end up
as unobservable mu nu tree knows
once they leaves the Sun and come to
earth and that would explain how it
comes that the that neutrinos from the
Sun are not observable on the earth that
clearly is going too far because after
our mr. Davis did observe some neutrinos
not enough but some and this is an
important point
so conversely if the neutrino is made
you know it has a lesser energy then at
the density at the center of the Sun it
would be somewhere on this curve
remember what matters is the product of
the density times the electron you times
the energy of the neutrino so neutrinos
of lesser energy then might be produced
here and as you would use the density as
the neutrino goes out of the Sun it goes
down the purple curve and ends up as an
electron neutrino so the simplest
including what you made or is the
high-energy neutrinos will be created
here and will be unobservable the
low-energy
lower energy neutrinos will be created
here and when they main electron
neutrinos and they main therefore
observable that is the theory of Malaya
and and Murano some are translated into
different different language quite apart
from being translated from Washington to
English and so let's see what we can
conclude for that I go to the paper
which I which I
mentioned before which says that from
1/8 you get forced new from all other
nuclei you get one and a half
Davis has observed two point one and so
I say these neutrinos are low energy
neutrinos and therefore are green no I
prefer and and are therefore observable
and also a few of the born eight
neutrinos must be observer may be 0.5
plus or minus 0.5 not clear whether any
of them need to be of the other
I evaluated this wrongly fouler then
collected me in a letter and the result
is that the born eight neutrinos zero if
they have less than 8 MeV and that leads
to a difference in mass graph between
the two types of neutrinos of 10 to the
minus 4 electron white square it means
by by the way very importantly this
works only if the Munich we know has a
higher mass than the electron neutrino
and so if we assume tentatively the
electron neutrino has no mass then the
new neutrino would have a mass of 100 of
an electron what totally unobservable by
other means
now that's not the only condition you
also need to have as the neutrinos go
out of the Sun you have to have an
adiabatic transition well that gives the
certain condition and I will not bother
you with the details it tells you that
the coupling and the you remember
electron neutrinos are cosine theta
times nu 1 plus sine theta times nu 2
that this coupling anger must be greater
than 0.01 Radian which is 0.6 degrees
it's almost certain if there is a
coupling angle at all that it will be
greater than this number for instance
those of you who know particle physics
where remember that the khabib or anger
is about 30 degrees much much larger
than 0.6 degrees so it is essentially
certain that the angle is big enough
however it says one very important thing
namely that both neutrinos must have
mass and that is not at all obvious when
we started talking about neutrinos back
50 years ago we thought I think
practically all of us of neutrinos
without any mass and they have great
attraction aesthetically but I have no
preconceived notion so I am perfectly
satisfied if neutrinos have some mass it
will be very very small
so if all this theory is correct then it
says that we don't observe those four
and eight neutrinos and only the bar and
eight neutrinos are converted into Mew
Utley knows and if you remember the
table I showed you at one time if you
use a gallium detector then you do not
preferentially observe 180 neutrinos but
instead you observe our neutrinos and
particularly though is coming directly
from the Porten Porten
reaction so with a gallium detector you
should observe essentially the same as
the fearless have always predicted you
should get the theoretical result which
is about a hundred and ten snow so we
have to hope for the Europeans to get
experiments with the gallium detector
where I have shown you the qualitative
analytic discussion which I have made
but there are people who are much more
industrious than I and know how to use a
computer which I don't and they found
then not only one solution of the
problem but two and the first people who
did that were the Russians themselves
and then with somewhat improved
technique it was done by Rosen and Gail
at Los Alamos and got these results now
if you believe that david observes
one-third of the expected neutrinos you
should use the diamonds the more recent
ideas of Pakal are that he observed only
a quarter and then you should look at
the circles and so what is plotted here
is Delta M square in electron volt
square and ten to the minus four is my
solution constant mass arbitrary
coupling anger theater but there's a
second solution which is shown here with
much smaller mass difference you would
have thought in two minus four is small
enough but they get even less and but
with a definite relation between the
mass difference and the coupling and in
fact the relation is that the product of
these two is a certain number it is
they're 2m squared times sine square of
the coupling anger is 4 times 10 to the
minus 8 electron Watts square small
enough they have confirmed the solution
which I published in addition to this
now if Delta M square is less then my 10
to the minus 4 then also neutrinos other
than the wall on your trainers will be
converted into mu nu trainers and but we
know that we must have some neutrinos
left over because after all Davis did
observe 1/3 or 1/4 of the expected
number so there must be some other
condition which prevents the conversion
of the electron neutrinos interview
neutrinos and that's the the condition
that the transition be adiabatic this
was pointed out not by Rosen and Caleb
but by Haxton of the University of
Washington and he has shown that the
ausangate solution essentially
corresponds to the a lab in a better
condition which i mentioned before and
assuming that Jackson finds analytically
that this product should be 6 10 to the
minus 8 closely enough to the 4 10 to
the minus 8 that always and then get
found
now because low energy neutrinos are now
lost the gallium experiment which
measures mostly low energy neutrinos
will not also give a response less than
the original theory if the second
solution is correct
I'll show you here
another nice curve of rosin in Canada
which tells you the probability of
reaching the earth as a function of the
energy in MA B and there is the Stars
which is my solution
you have practically no probability for
the high-energy neutrino but all the low
energy neutrinos where they main
electron neutrinos and be observable and
contrariwise father was killed solution
it's the other way around
so the gallium experiment the fr has
become even more important it will make
it possible to distinguish the two
solutions
the question was raised is there any
upper limit to sine square theta this
was investigated by our group who found
yes there is the upper limit is
something like a half the way to Syrians
actually essentially independent of the
mass difference the best calculation so
far has been made by two people at
Fermilab Park and Walker who plot here
some beautiful couriers it all uses the
same general idea namely conversion of
neutrinos from electron neutrinos to mew
neutrinos in the Sun due to high density
of the matter in the Sun plotted here is
again the difference in mass between the
two types of neutrinos plotted here is
essentially the sine square of two theta
and the contour lines correspond to
various possible results of the Davis
experiment what he gives is 2.1 snoo
that's this curve but he says plus or
minus 0.3 that's three times for the
hour so it can be anything between 1.8
and 2.4 all right if you follow the 2.1
curve there's first a horizontal stretch
which is my 10 to the minus 4 mass
difference then there is the slant line
which is essentially the horse and help
solution it
the wiggle because different different
types of neutrinos undergo the
non-adiabatic transition which goes to
smaller mass difference and higher
science Square Theatre and finally there
is the vertical line which is
essentially the Suckley limit at high
coupling anger so this tells you then
you have essentially two solutions to
the problem either the master for the
stent of minus four and then the
coupling under candy anything oils the
mass difference is much less than ten to
minus four and then the coupling anger
must be directly related to the through
the mass difference where the Fermilab
people Park Park and Walker then went on
and discussed what should be the result
of the gallium experiment once it is
done and that now is particularly
interesting this again is mass
difference anger and the dotted lines
are the two limits after Davis
experiment with chlorine the solid lines
are the contour lines for the gallium
experiment to be done and so you see if
the solution is along this line or along
this line then the gallium experiment
should give or somewhere between 100 and
120 Snoop but if the solution is the
type preferred by us and then get
then the gallium experiment will give
you a greatly reduced count maybe as low
as 10 snow 10% of the theoretically
predicted number so this is extremely
interesting and makes off gosh the
gallium extreme and more and more
important and so what can we conclude if
the guy whom experiment gives the high
value about a hundreds new then there
are two alternatives either my original
interpretation of the two of the Russian
suggestion is the right one the mass
difference is ten to the minus four and
the anger is undetermined or there is
some totally unknown other explanation
now because we as that his theory of the
temperature distribution of the Sun is
correct so it's very unlikely that
there's another explanation however one
would have to say if gallium gives a
hundred snoo or so then the behave
Smirnov explanation is merely likely it
is not absolutely proved but if the
gallium experiment gives a much lower
number let us say something less than 60
perhaps as low as 10 snow then that can
only be explained by the by the Russian
suggestion because there is nothing that
we can do about the distribution of
temperature in the Sun which would
reduce the number of Porten Porten
reactions because look those reactions
give you our give us our light we know
exactly how much energy the Sun image
and so we know exactly how many Porten
Porten collisions occur and therefore no
change of the solar temperature
distribution could explain a gallium
result anywhere in that region in that
case then we behaved Smirnov answer fury
is definitely proved and we must then
assume that indeed neutrinos have a mass
that the mass of the neutrino is greater
than that of the electron neutrino and
how much it is can be determined then
from the gallium experiment if the
gallium experiment gives the high value
then the one for me has to do still
another experiment showing that the that
it is indeed the Russian suggestion and
not
something funny about the Sun that gives
the that is the cause of the Davis
result if gallium is as low as about
tents knew then that I am squares of
honor ten to the minus six and sine
square of two theta is of the order of
0.1 and that's very close to the bebo
angle which would be 0.16 there is no
good reason why it should be just the
khabib oh now the most exciting part of
this whole story it is that it might
permit us a glimpse into the gut and by
this I don't mean the intestines but I
mean the grand unified theory that
particle cos are fond of and of which I
understand nothing
however my particle theorist tell me
that in what you there should be
right-handed neutrinos in addition to
the ones we know which are left-handed
neutrinos and he's right-handed neutrino
should have a mass about equal to the
grand unification mass which is 10 to
the 14 GeV or 10 to the 23
evey so we are talking at the same time
about terribly small masses and terribly
big masses there is in particular theory
by Gelman and two others simultaneously
obtained by yanagida in 78 and 79
according to which the mass of neutrinos
of a given flavor I should be the mask
we're off the corresponding clock
divided by some constant and the mass of
the grand unification theory of course
that mass nobody knows but it is about
that number why the K appears there I
haven't any idea
the mune your trainer would have Tenten
minus 6 e V and the Tau neutrino 10 to
the minus 3 e V with the right-handed
neutrino is having a mass like the gut
mass it is obvious that the neutrino
would then not be enough to satisfy any
solution of the solar neutrino parser
only the Tau neutrino would the
difference of the square of the town
neutrino and union a neutrino mass would
be 10 to the minus 6 e v square which
falls right into the range of the boys
and girl solution and it falls right at
the place where gallium would give the
minimum response of about 10 snoo so we
must then assume that in the Sun the
electron neutrino converts into a Tau
neutrino not immune you're cleaner at
present I don't know any experiment
which would distinguish between tau and
new neutrino as the product and but you
can see that it will be most exciting to
have the result of the gallium
experiment this can first of all show
whether or not the vkf Smirnov
suggestion is correct and whether this
is the solution of the solar neutrino
puzzle and secondly it may give us an
insight into a grand unified theory and
insight into things which occur at
energies of 10 to the 14 GeV energies
which surely are beyond the most
ambitious plans of accelerators and
surely and and which also are beyond the
range of cosmic light neutrinos they go
up to about 10 to the 20th evey whereas
the gut is about 10 to the 23rd AV so it
there is a good chance I believe that
the neutrinos will give us a look into
energy is so high that we have no
reasonable expectation of reaching them
by accelerators or other observations
and if that is so then it was most
fortunate that lei Davis did not observe
the neutrinos that were expected but
observed only a small fraction of them
and no matter how much the theorists
pressed him he still stuck to his small
number and this may have shown us very
interesting feature of neutrino physics
and possibly the best hand at knowing
something about the very highest energy
particle physics thank you
[Applause]